white house getting caught in a major
lie about the price tag of president
biden's massive socialist spending spree
this comes after the administration and
allies spent another weekend continuing
to push the idea that the multi-trillion
dollar plan wouldn't cost americans a
dime
what we've said from the beginning is
it's never been about the price tag it's
about what we want to deliver we don't
look at this as a number we look at this
as what programs are we going to deliver
president biden has been a good faith
partner to the entire democratic party
he reaches out and he actually
tries to understand our perspective and
that is why i am fighting for his agenda
with the build back better act this
conversation shouldn't be about numbers
and just a few hours ago at the white
house gensake forced to admit the butt
administration has been misleading
americans
following up on something that you just
said you said that the president's going
to have a virtual meeting with house
progressives to talk about how this
buildback better package is now going to
be smaller than three and a half
trillion dollars but you have been
saying that it cost zero so are you now
admitting that the plan does not cost
zero or is it less than zero well
let's let's not dumb this down for the
american public here so the point is
that's important to the american public
all of your viewers too is that this is
not going to cost the american public a
dollar so just to not dumb it down then
does the plan cost nothing or is the
plan free the plan costs nothing for the
american people who make less than four
hundred thousand dollars
that was our very own peter ducey data
very young not a bad question do you
think he got anywhere with that well i
think so mostly because i believe that
people understand what's going on feel
like some of the polling for
independents looking at this they're
like 72 against it it's not that they
it's not that you wouldn't say yeah free
college sounds amazing and so does free
child care like it all sounds great but
then you dig one question deeper and
they're not there for that
so
we said in the uh harold you mentioned
in the first block that biden beat
bernie
in the primary well
he said i'm the moderate he said i'm not
a socialist like i'm obviously the
moderate but right now bernie is the
face of the administration he's the one
out there
calling for the sixth street saying well
we'll take 3.5 trillion though it really
should have been six he's out there
really helping aoc is out there jai
paul's out there where are the moderates
they're basically like wow we just got
kicked in the face
by the president and so
the fact that they are continuing to say
things like it costs zero reminds me of
when the white house also tried to say
that republicans were the ones that
defunded the police
it doesn't actually wash people actually
don't get it the last thing i would say
is that the summer of disasters that we
saw is turning into the fall of failures
and one of the things that is happening
is that people are really focused on
inflation
that is the thing to watch that people
are concerned about it the fed says it's
temporary but when people start seeing
that meat cost 28 more than
what they've been paying that they start
to feel that then there should be the
winter of woe dana and then after that
we shall the spring of suffering perfect
you want to take this craig go ahead
you're all hopped up no i was very
excited by that uh the economy is like a
sinking ship and it's operational as
long as you have the buckets to empty
the water out and we are the buckets the
taxpayers are the buckets the money
doesn't exist
even after it's spent so you have to get
more and more buckets basically we're
funding a multi-marketing scheme and
maybe that's the way government's always
been and i just realized it now but the
fact is you know i'm going to spend
money i don't have don't worry i will
tax you then by the time we get that
money from you there's already another
spending bill right and then what do i
do with that well that's not going to
cost you anything because i'm going to
tax you later so it's this thing that
keeps going it is like a it's a it's a
pyramid scheme but maybe that's what
it always has been and i was naive not
to see it
you're not naive greg oh thanks come on
be better than that
so
to greg's naive point
you're establishing these trillion
dollar programs that are going to
eventually go away and then they're
going to need to be refunded kennedy so
you're setting it up here and now the
new spending level is now multi-trillion
dollars each year isn't it insane that
do you remember when the the stimulus
passed back in 2008 and and we were all
like oh my gosh this is insane 800
billion dollars we thought that was a
lot never afford this i could barely say
the words yeah and republicans were so
mad at president obama and it was just
you know it was such a phenomenal number
and now we're going that 2 trillion 3
trillion bernie's like 6 trillion that's
where i want to start you know it's like
joe manchin's like
1.5 is my ceiling bernie's like 6
trillion is my floor there's a lot of
real estate in between and no one is
being honest about the fact that yes
taxation is theft there's no such thing
as a government investment government
cannot earn money government does not
create things that create revenue they
reach into your bank account and now
they want to do it with the irs every
expenditure you have over six hundred
dollars the the irs wants banks to tell
them what you're spending money on every
single purchase over 600
that is a taking they are taking money
they are taking information and the
american public plenty of them who make
less than 400 000 a year are getting
absolutely hosed yeah what do you think
about that the feds want to look at
everything over 600 in your checking
account
do you think that's cool i think that's
wrong and i hope that's taken out of the
bill but let's put some in perspective
here in the 80s we spent
billions of dollars hundreds of billions
of dollars on defense spending and i
think it created it was an investment in
our country it was an investment in
taking down communism and we found the
internet out of it there was an enormous
amount of attendant technologies that
came from it one of the reasons i think
you have the private sector partnering
with the public sector to send people
with space is because they're going to
be so many things that we learn so many
ways that our phones will work better so
many ways that telecommunications and
for that matter all communication
services will do better now i don't
necessarily call we can quarrel about
whether or not there's enough in here to
do all of those kinds of things but
government does do smart things and can
do smart things now in this bill here i
differ slightly with everybody droning
children that was the same standards
bernie sanders is not the face of my
party uh if we're gonna look at the face
right now the democratic party's
probably joe manchin i mean people have
been hearing people on network say
there's big joe and little joe and i
think they're calling joe biden little
joe joe manchin uh is the most important
person domestic policy in the country
yeah but they all can't stand him on the
democratic side i think i think to
greg's point i think there are a lot of
people hiding behind him too i think a
few people are hiding behind him yeah so
anyway we got a big fight here it's now
one point five to two point one is what
this thing will be yeah
3.5.5 trillion is the moderate proposal
then my head is going to explode harold
that is oh no crazy i'm just putting the
numbers in person now we can hold that
perspective it's crazy and we can't
afford it and you know it and so i don't
want your head to explode jesse
what happens to your hair your beautiful
hair you should talk your hair is higher
than mine was last year closer to god
what number can you accept where your
head won't explode
you don't need me to tell people what my
number is i'm not even in congress yet
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else